hey guys just a quick one here okay so
obviously the Internet has been pretty
rife with speculation on the time-travel
elements of Avengers and game after
footage of the heroes back at the Battle
of New York leaked and behind the scenes
shots however in addition to this it
seems like Marvel may have accidentally
confirmed that this is the case with the
reprinting of a 1969 comic book issue
this issue
Avengers 71 titled endgame involves time
travel and sees the Avengers going back
in time to earn their lives back whilst
the issue sees a face-off between the
Grandmaster and Kang which probably
won't be featured in the film the other
similarities are pretty apparent Marvel
are clearly printing this to coincide
with the release of their big
blockbuster so this seems like a massive
red flag for fans of the comics and of
course love to hear your thoughts on
this news and if you think it will
finally confirm what we've all been
expecting comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video please
like it and make sure you check out my
fan theory on why I think Tony Stark
isn't dead in spider-man far from home
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for take the
time to watch this I've been definition
that you've been the best now see you
next time take care peace
you
[Music]